[Music]
i play beth
she's an every woman sort of character
she's a teacher she's you know has a
sort of regular life but when we first
meet her she is returning from her
husband's funeral we don't really know
how he's died but sort of like revealed
in pieces what has happened in her life
over the last four days he took the boat
out on the lake he took a handgun that i
didn't even know that we owned
and pow
to completely pull the rug out from
under her feet and the question of
why did he do this
did he leave a note he did
she's remarkably reckless you were right
and she's not sleeping
there is nothing and she doesn't know
what's real and what isn't anymore
nothing is after you
[Music]
you're safe now
rebecca's incredible
there was a raw sensibility to her
approach that was really really exciting
to me we just had to play it from the
gut
i think beth and owen had a good
marriage they were happy they'd been
together for a very long time
how long were you married this next one
would have been 15. wow
remember young
and i think there's some carelessness in
that relationship
i didn't think we had secrets
an assumption that they know everything
about each other
evan jonah had a really unique challenge
in this because he's playing both her
husband owen but he's also playing a
vision of what we call the entity
you're really here yeah
i'm like you felt when your heart
stopped evan and i just knew
we're gonna get weird
owen embeds himself into the audience's
mind
and then just lingers there the ability
to play a guy who is felt but not seen
is something that just drew me in tell
me everything that you know
what did he say then he had urges mel's
a character who's there to help but
there's also a suspicion built around
him so they'd found a way to
keep them at bay there's also a sarah
goldberg as claire
i think an interesting challenge is the
best friend he said you were safe
safe from one she doesn't really grasp
in its entirety full depth of beth is
experienced
it's just great to have good actors you
know work with great dialogue you're
just audience to many truths that
they're finding within the scene
[Music]
you